one year ago tonight the Washington
girls studied the safety of their
parents Lodge I'm an endowment so we can
see the subtitles and people know
awesome answers we're going to change
the control options to traditional
genetic you know it was making me juicy
it
you won't see a toy this pumpkin was
money episodes that was the old man yes
this is up for great stop is it the same
one because it was a guy when I found a
guy with a flamethrower
no Ivan well I think normal is just an
awfully anxious when everyone's or I
mean you could really going for a hike
21:02 what time is that
no no that's pretty like it I think it's
just really cold
no gloves no gloves
you'd be freezing this is yeah everybody
people are crazy
there's a note there's an image gates
supposed to climb I look I really need
to grab that it's gonna make me grab
this ugly well maybe I think it know if
it's something I can take your
interactors it'll it'll Whittle like
that
so I think the idea is that once we grab
them start to decline because she
couldn't breathe it from a distance try
to put it anyway
I'm just trying to figure out how the
controls work here is it easier that
wasn't but I think it probably will be
fun things it was that ago sick quick
okay that's weird go back to where we
were
that's really confusing I keep wanting
to because I'm used to it press the left
stick to make decisions gentle climb
keep doing the wrong one keep wanting to
choose five the West is a huge edge but
it's the right stick because I expected
to like have to choose it with pricks of
eggs to select it but it's not is it
different it's different from other
games watch
the princi it's pretty
yeah I'm just carrying around dance with
me clean my pockets whenever I go in the
woods you don't double one that's that
yeah this is good relationship Stella
that's interesting so what is the Blue
Girl mean I would guess more blue it is
the stronger the relationship use with
that person so she's not real fun to
Jason like Mike is dick I'm like is it
he was the one who effectively yes the
fate for her yes she's brave she's
charitable she's opponents not very
funny
no no funny actually she doesn't seem
worth it when he plays she doesn't know
really she's done she's honest and real
others on this TSP to me she's a good
one
she might be a keeper so every time we
meet a new person we can do that and
whatever just yeah that's a good thing
to do
yeah much I thought I would we did come
up with a couple of them when you first
like two differences did you see when
you have trouble and yeah this is it
Trump C once lived in these mountains
okay so technically is Lea thought flies
carry dreams and fluxes of possible
futures called a butterfly indicate the
nature in most so dis is black danger
wait go ahead then because II truly mean
that she was right again it butterflies
I'm sure it'll be so maybe the toys
won't have a yes okay let's see fallout
is about a month away the future is
uncertain whether or not the prophecy
was true
hello us guidance oh great so you can do
that means that me guidance what does
that mean can it lead you in on a path
it's gonna guide you and you're not
necessarily good or bad though
no I'm wondering if you know I don't
know that means pretty buddies if they
weren't creepy over time something that
might Saunders when you're supposed to
go over there something you can interact
with the hikes is beyond our control
it is indeed thanks Captain Obvious very
helpful information but it creases in
the back
yeah sponsor me he's not bad yeah good
to answer it no it's just uh great that
that's why I've got real Ashley Chris
has a crush on Ashley methodical
protective humors cool I'm sorry cool
well thanks for letting knowing I'm
probably pretty pissed I found someone
doing that to me too to be honest it was
he oh I found something
okay do you know
he's supposed to think it kind of wants
me to but I bring the gun who cares
it's nothing but dealing with the dragon
here mum and Vic do the dragon terrify
the BB guns one weakness yeah it's just
emotional wrecks right now like to be
friends
returning wow yeah I don't understand
that it seems but it does so they found
something else
yeah maybe
so they have to win if Josh was the one
who walked in and get Christian just say
right easy how do you want to melt me I
love the shoes
now they've it's done it's cool so I'm
controlling personnel oh yeah I didn't
know you're allowed to do that it's what
I won't say about that please to stand
up yeah and really impressed by the
young what's a new language
I mean
well you know what let's just you know
third-grade Josh at the back of the room
I sat in front we know each other
existed but the kid sitting next to Josh
started straps tapping the training bra
the teacher made her move to the front
and that's the job so we met the amount
of fingers have to be like it all to
have yet
no you could be riding in this cable car
alone right now or we're talking to some
other person entirely
it's true the amount of stuff that I
stole I ever literally you to meet
someone we can be friendly and it
changes every yeah yeah